[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici lé titre il a connu de nombreuses
fonctions depuis sa création il ya 45
ans le silo situé dans le quartier du
val hibou à plaisir est en cours de
démolition il doit laisser place à de
nouveaux aménagements en construction
d'un centre commercial et d'une nouvelle
place pour revitaliser le quartier
le joli mois de l'europe débarque samedi
à saint quentin en yvelines une journée
pédagogique et d'information autour des
financements européens a prévu devant la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
pour en parler nous recevrons jean
michel fourgous le président de
l'agglomération dans le reste de
l'actualité retour sur le challenge ski
robe dédié à la programmation robotique
pour les écoliers de l'agglomération
encore l'extraction challenge des
pompiers et qui se poursuivent au
vélodrome elle national de saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est un bâtiment emblématique du
quartier du val hibou à plaisir mais
c'est aussi devenu un poids depuis
quelques années pour ses habitants et la
commune le silo va être détruit au
profit d'une grande place avec de
nouveaux équipements plus modernes la
destruction du site a débuté fin avril
objectif ouvrir le quartier du val hibou
sur le reste de la ville et favoriser
aussi la mixité sociale les explications
avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
grégory canal est il a accueilli à la
fois un parking des services de la ville
et aussi des commerces depuis sa
construction en 1973 les fonctions du
silo de plaisir ont évolué un lieu de
vie pour les habitants du valais bout
tombé en désuétude depuis quelques
années le bâtiment avait l'inconvénient
de renfermer le quartier sur lui-même sa
destruction entreprises fin avril était
devenue inévitable
on s'est rendu compte que c'était quand
même un endroit un peu trop replié sur
lui-même qui posait problème
et puisque nous sommes surtout
aujourd'hui dans une refonte complète du
quartier bien il était véritablement
question que ce bâtiment qui devenait
obsolète dangereux puissent être démoli
une étude de faisabilité a été lancée
pour décider du futur de cette place
les résultats devraient être dévoilés
d'ici la rentrée de septembre des
commerces et équipements municipaux
pourraient y voir le jour et les travaux
seront menés par plusieurs partenaires
le bailleur résidence yvelines essonne
propriétaire du silo la ville de plaisir
et mais aussi l'état dans le cadre de la
rénovation urbaine sur cette place est
bien on aura une visibilité de quelque
chose de beaucoup plus claires et
précises
en tout cas on veut que ce soit ouvert
au quartier donc tu aura certainement je
dirais quelque chose qui va ressembler
peut-être à une esplanade
mais comme le quartier sera ouverte ça
sera plus uniquement dédié uniquement au
quartier du baby boom et à l'ensemble de
la collectivité une destruction du silo
qui fait partie d'un projet plus global
celui de changer l'image du vélib ou la
réhabilitation de cet ensemble social
est en cours de nouvelles fresques
viendront bientôt en délire les murs du
quartier
on connaîtra son successeur mardi soir
jean-pierre sevestre le maire de
coignières démissionne de son mandat de
vice-président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines les lure en
charge des sports quitte ses fonctions
pour des raisons de santé des problèmes
qu'ils ont déjà poussé à fin avril à se
mettre en retrait à coignières depuis un
mois c'est son adjoint aux finances
david pelletier qui assure les affaires
courantes
une démission qui tombe mal pour saint
quentin en yvelines à quelques semaines
seulement de la ryder cup qui se tiendra
à précisément du 28 au 30 30 septembre
prochain au golf national à lui en cours
jean michel fourgous bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de
l'agglomération une réaction peut être
sur cette actualité est ce que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle je le disais pour
l'agglomération est ce que vous prenez
du retard du coup dans l'organisation de
cette compétition au mois de septembre
c'est vrai que des compétitions du
niveau au saint quentin volley il ya une
grosse compétitivité économique pour nos
jeunes entreprises et sportives et et
sportives et scientifiques aussi bien
sûr et les gens qui mènent ses
responsabilités
sont menées à dure épreuve et c'est vrai
que c'est ce poste de vice président
bien sûr aux sports est assez à ces
événements là est un est une très lourde
fonction aussi à la ryder cup et à
l'arrivée un peu plus toutes les
animations qui lie à sur les classes de
lune c'est bien ce que vous prenez du
repos mais le nombre d'événements à
couvrir pour le celui qui elles peuvent
se des sports est effectivement un peu
ce serait difficile et la ryder cup bien
sûr la salle à l'intensification et
massive et c'est vrai que ce semestre
qui en plus un petit problème bien sûr
avec sa hanche qui va se faire opérer
donc cessé quand c'est vrai que voir ces
deux postes et mer et à l'intercours
saint-quentin avoir ce policier
effectivement c'est très gros pour lui
il a souhaité m'a dit qu'il fallait que
qui prennent un peu bien sûr de 2,2 de
marge de manoeuvre pour ce sera pas
l'impasse qui est tout à fait normal ses
priorités
non c'est pas en bien sûr enfin ont bien
sûr 2 mai les achats mondiaux d'autres
bien sûr on compense mai mais c'est vrai
que c'est faut bien se rendre compte que
c'est des postes quand même très lourd
de responsabilités et bien sûr et lui
mais je comprends très bien et il a déjà
son poste de maire il faut du coup
est-ce que vous avez un nom à nous
donner je comprends bien lancé mardi
soir puisque ça sera soumis au vote des
élus communautaires forcément mardi soir
il faut quelqu'un à une avec une
certaine stature j'imagine pour pour
assumer un tel rôle est ce que vous avez
un nom est ce que vous pouvez dévoilé un
an ou alors ce sera mardi soir non
rassurez vous ça ne manque pas bien sûr
des gens qui souhaitent ce genre de
responsabilités bien sûr mais c'est
encore à rendre des arbitrages avec
l'équipe dans les quelques heures qui
vous voilà donc vous sera je pense dans
les jours qui viennent tout cas une
remarque juste une réflexion se fait
cette annonce au tour de jean-pierre
sevestre arrive fruit du hasard ou
plutôt autour de l'actualité sur la
fusion avec avec maurepas est-ce que
vous en tant que président de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous étiez favorable à cette fusion est
ce que vous êtes déçu que le projet soit
abandonné
non mais que les chutes de dotation de
près de 20% sur les communes de france
les 36000 communes de france
bien sûr que c'est très difficile on vit
tous c'est un moment difficile et ça
pousse les communes à se rapprocher
fusionner m près de 1000 beaucoup ces
tensions de fusion en france est une
nouvelle que lé alors maintenant
maurepas et quoi venir avait évoqué cela
c'est pas simple visiblement donc d
entrée
j'avais évoqué l'éventualité mais comme
j'évoque aussi l'éventualité que
communautaire mais savoir inventer
demain deux ou trois communes qui nous
rejoignent qui ont cette culture
économique et qui veulent participer aux
grands projets de développement
économique de saint quentin où on a
dénombré hier un pour pouvoir passer à
un quart de million et 235 mm à peu près
donc 250 villes et là effectivement ça
fait combien horbette vous posez
beaucoup plus dans des arbitrages
internationaux sur des aides à
l'innovation on est on est bien sur le
coeur économique de paris saclay vous le
savez qui est un des plus beaux projets
d'innovation et de recherche en france
bien sûr que pour monter les dossiers on
pèse plus en communauté urbaine ce qu'on
fait partie d'un club des onze 11
communes urbaines par rapport à le club
des 222 je crois deux communautés
d'agglomération
une dernière question sur ce sujet avant
de passer au joli mois de l'europe à
saint quentin en yvelines
certains évoquent une éventuelle en
projet de fusion aussi dans quelques
années ou à très peu de temps à moyen
terme au court terme entre les locaux à
maurepas
est ce que ce sont que des rumeurs ou là
aussi et des éventuelles discussions qui
existent coude et moi je suis fermé à
rien parce que si on continue comme ça
étrangler les 2 1 on nous parle qu'on va
enlever la taxe d'habitation sans que le
gouvernement ait le moindre début d'une
idée sérieuse il faut servir la façon
dont il va couvrir les coûts de 27
milliards enfin il vient de voter comme
un déficit budgétaire de 84 milliards
allait dire je vais baisser les impôts
donc c'est bon c'est pas sérieux bon
donc j'espère d'abord je souhaite qu'ils
retirent 7,7 cette annonce et qui n'est
pas crédible et enfin la situation des
collectivités permet pas d'aller en plus
enlever les taxes d'habitation et puis
personne se plaint et puis personne
vient me voir monsieur le maire est ce
que tu es ce que vous et l'angélisme
personnes c'est un impôt qui était
accepté la loi encourageant plus la
fusion des communes pour alors bien sûr
à chaque fois que vous enlevez comme ça
des recettes pour les communes ou les
mettent en difficulté enfin on paye les
écoles on paye les crèches en paye les
routes on paye faut se rendre compte de
ce que c'est que
samedi services sociaux les services
techniques sera bon bon bref
c'est vrai que donc ça on voit les les
collectivités à se dire - est-ce qu'on
va fusionner est ce que on va passer en
communauté urbaine tout le monde se pose
des questions dont il ya pas que l en
cours ou à nos repas ou au poignet pour
l'instant rien n'est arrêté de
l'animation il ya des négociations nous
aujourd'hui on est plus à la réflexion
sur la communauté urbaine que sur la
fusion de communes mais je veux dire
demain voilà et je sais que beaucoup de
mes collègues dans les yvelines mais
aussi réfléchissent alors autre sujet
d'actualité on le disait samedi
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines fait l'europe avec une journée
d'animations spéciales devant la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux il y aura des ateliers et
surtout des explications et détails qui
sont donnés sur les fonds européens
le but en fait c'est de faire un peu de
publicité pour l'europe montré que
l'europe ce n'est pas que des soucis ou
des problèmes pour les collectivités
pour l'état mais c'est aussi des moyens
qui sont qui existent mais d'abord sur
le mandat des députés européens c'est 27
milliards en 2014 2020 ses 27 milliards
qui sont dédiés aux éditions pour la
redistribuer sur la france quand même
bon beaucoup sur le
l'innovation l'europe est très porteuse
d des dossiers d'innovation d'ailleurs
nous je vous rappelle qu'on est dans
l'es8 aux deux mondial d'innovation
s'est pas relevé mighty donc mais si on
a la chance d'avoir pas mal de soutien
de l'europe
deuxièmement
donc saint quentin paris saclay
et conseil départemental si on s'attache
aux sciences sociales se désengage peut
se tourner vers vers l'union européenne
c'est aussi pour ça une telle journée
montrer qu'il ya de l'argent à aller
chercher que que l'union européenne peut
soutenir les collectivités en lieu et
place de l'état
oui et 2 passes et d'ailleurs en
communauté urbaine de peser un quart de
million et bien sûr avec les éléments
mais sûr que c'est plus simple de pour
négocier avec le club des scènes dans
lequel on est le club des 5 c'est quoi
c'est saint quentin paris saclay
département des yvelines région
ile-de-france région ile de france est
donc bien sûr que on sera amené un peu
plus négocier avec avec l'europe
sipa un demain il y avait encore des
lâchages de la part de l'état
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il ya quand même
même on a encore eu 5 millions pour
l'obs à la préservation énergétique de
certains bâtiments j'allais vous ces
expériences et 5 millions d'euros des
fonds européens
ça sera à rénover les bâtiments
principalement rénover les bâtiments
avec des moyens énergétiques très
innovant ça sert aussi à on a dû dire
presque un demi million pour notre
incubateur l'incubateur c'est
l'accompagnement des jeunes chefs
d'entreprise des start-up fais moi
j'étais il ya quelques instituts bas
comme on dit j'ai monté une certain pour
monter dans le numérique
j'aurais aimé avoir leur incubateur
comme ça financé par l'europe qui
m'expliquait tout la bêtise à ne pas
faire quand vous êtes jeune machin vous
fait plein de bêtises on en crée autant
grise vous hésitez ou et effectivement
c'est une sécurisation
quand même très forte pour pour faire
réussir nos jeunes entrepreneurs à saint
quentin et il ya également beaucoup de
fonds qui vont sur les fonds sociaux
européens
de fait ce qui est dans l'insertion et
insertion donc tous qui emploie un petit
peu comment ça c'est une journée
pédagogique justement pour dire ça aux
saint quentinois absolument exit est
absolument et c'est important parce que
l'idh les gens de et en plus il faut
bien savoir que vous parlez de la ryder
cup et la ryder cup demain ça va être
les ondes contre les amériques vient
rencontre entre les deux plus gros les
deux premières puissances mondiales
aujourd'hui que son
les etats unis l'europe on est à peu
près équivalent on laisse des gens un
petit peu plus joli mais très très
légèrement
on est à peu près équivalent de
production de richesse mondiale donc
c'est un sacré symbole que que d'avoir
sa der aussi dans notre agglomération
c'est une rencontre où vous deviez vous
êtes je crois trois ou quatre présidents
ou anciens présidents américains qui
sont présents et que donc c'est c'est
quand même et l'europe c'est quand même
aujourd'hui d'abord un généralement une
dernière question les hommes politiques
aiment bien se défausser un petit peu
sur l'europe critiquiez l'europe c'est
toujours la cible un peu facile est-ce
que vous en tant que président d'une
agglomération et maire d'elancourt vous
êtes plutôt europhile que euros critique
vous savez comme comme dit un garçon que
celle de thierry marx qui a monté une
chaîne de restaurants extraordinaire il
dit dans la vie il ya ceux qui cherchent
les coupables et puis il ya ceux qui
créent la richesse qui crée allait
montrer très large
je suis en six heures en tout cas je
suis aussi que les jeux les faits dans
le passé aussi où j'ai accompagnent ceux
qui créent la richesse l'emploi qui font
le bien
plutôt que de chercher narcissiquement à
être donner des leçons de morale sur le
passé sur les coupables sur voila quand
il ya des trucs grave la justice s'en
occupe en tout cas voilà en tout cas
avec l'europe à préparer l'avenir
l'europe
indiscutablement aide à préparer
l'avenir les secteurs en tout cas qu'ils
ont envie de faire bouger les choses et
il ya du coup un rendez vous demain
devant la médiathèque du canada montigny
le bretonneux de 10 heures à 18 heures
il ya aussi un rendez vous le mercredi
30 mai au ski tu me l'as et pour les
entrepreneurs
jean michel fourgous vous restez avec
nous on passe maintenant au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
une retraite annoncée à 49 ans david
douillet va quitter la vie politique il
l'a confirmé mardi dans une interview
donnée à nos confrères du parisien
l'actuel président de la fédération
l'est républicain des civils ne sera pas
candidat à sa succession en octobre
l'élu va tout de même terminé son mandat
de conseiller régional lr qui court
jusqu'en 2021 et david douillet se dit
notamment déçu dans cette interview par
des cadres du parti et ne partage pas la
ligne actuelle de son président national
laurent wauquiez pour lui succéder à la
tête de la fédération l ère des yvelines
trois candidats sont connus parmi eux le
président du département des yvelines
pierre bédier et la conseillère
régionale alexandra dublanche jean
michel fourgous avant de vous quitter
une petite question forcément sur cette
actualité qui agite le monde politique
local qui allez vous soutenir vous entre
pierre bédier alexandra du blanche qui
forment un ticket avec othman nasro que
vous connaissez bien conseiller
communautaire et conseiller municipal à
trappes
il a écouté une g5 concis départementaux
dans mon administration et j'ai deux
voire trois d'ailleurs conseillers
régionaux
donc c'est une élection tout à fait
légitime
en tout cas moi j'ai besoin de tout le
monde saint quentin c'est plutôt
aujourd'hui une structure de
développement économique d'économies qui
fait aussi la richesse du pays les
emplois c'est moins une structure
politique que d'autres structures donc
moi je souhaite rester chez l'ensemble
des gens qui se présentent je les
connais dont certains sont des mutations
il est hors de question que
je me mêle de cette addiction d'ailleurs
je reste au dessus vraiment quand ils me
demandent une salle lors de nos salles
mais j'ai pas moi les moyens d'aller
jouer dès qu'on fait maintenant les uns
avec le non non non absolument
ils ont ils ont tous des qualités on a
besoin de tout le monde et que je serai
jusqu'à votre plan crédible pour eux
s'il ya eu des petites blessures de les
réconcilier son discours le plus pro
économique faveur éventuellement mais
d'ici au mois d'octobre
oui oui je pense que moi je suis très
valorisant c'est de bien sûr delà de
l'économie de la culture économique et
puis aussi des résultats que les gens
parce que les grandes déclarations c'est
bien aujourd'hui on a besoin vraiment de
de compétence économique de la france
est dans une situation difficile
c'est donc voila mais voila voila je jeu
ils ont toute mon estime
tous les deux et après je serai là pour
réconcilier s'il ya eu des petites
bestioles entre les uns et les autres
comptez sur moi merci jean michel
fourgous d'être venu en plateau vous
êtes le maire d'elancourt et président
de saint quentin en yvelines merci à
vous et bon week-end dans le reste de
l'actualité jeudi le prisme d'elancourt
accueillez la troisième édition du
challenge de robotique ski robe le
concept plus de 1000 élèves de la
maternelle au bts ont programmé à des
robots durant leur année scolaire pour
s'affronter
ensuite lors d'une compétition laure
machine devait réussir à boucler des
parcours devant un jury cette année le
rendez vous était focalisée sur la ryder
cup on en parlait il ya quelques
instants
miquel et demi d'euros et manon var ados
ont assisté justement à ce concours
regarder des robots déguisée des
supporters enthousiastes du stress
bienvenue la troisième édition du
challenge de robotique sky robe en
arrivant les 1000 élèves de 40
établissements n'ont qu'un objectif en
tête prouver qu'ils ont programmée le
robot parfait
ils ont envie de gagner effectivement il
ya quand même une compétition et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'ils ont été
motivé toute l'année pour faire des
efforts pour progresser pour résoudre
les bugs c'est bien parce qu'il ya une
compétition donc du coup un vrai projet
derrière
tous ont travaillé sur un cahier des
charges élaboré en lien avec l'éducation
nationale le thème la ryder cup 2018 qui
se tiendra en septembre à saint quentin
en yvelines
un jury spécialisé composé d'une dizaine
de personnes s'est chargé de noter cette
partie de mini golf 2.0 il s'est un
petit peu délicat parce qu'on sent
qu'ils ont travaillé ils peuvent être
parfois déçu parce que ça fonctionne pas
comme il le voudrait parce que les
conditions sont pas les mêmes qu'à
l'école évidemment les robots réagissent
pas toujours pareil il ya des pannes
parfois ils n'arrivent pas à les démarré
voilà des mésaventure qu'ont connus ses
élèves d'écoles primaires de trappes
c'est vraiment décevant parce qu'on a
vraiment travaillé et on avait on avait
réussi j'ai servant de venir on avait
bien réussi mais maintenant
c'est ma il ya des petits soucis ça
permet aux enfants aussi d'avoir le
droit à l'erreur donc on l'a vu
aujourd'hui ils sont préparés à ça ils
savent que le robot il n'avance pas tout
seul et il faut le programmer avant sur
un logiciel
d'autres au contraire ont vu leurs
investissements de l'année récompense et
c'est grâce au travail de l'école afin
de travailler travailler n'arrive
c'est parce qu'on à rusal pour ramener
bien à bien le programme et le challenge
sky robe reviendra l'année prochaine
pour une quatrième édition la thématique
devrait être annoncée en septembre
prochain
toujours dans cette thématique numérique
école à elancourt mardi et est inauguré
le projet bouge ta classe 10 classes
pilotes dans six écoles élémentaires
dispose notamment de nouveaux espaces
pédagogiques repenser réaménagé pour
faciliter l'enseignement des plus jeunes
ici les innovations concernent une
classe de cm2 à l'école de la
commanderie vous le voyez à l'écran
l'usagé des tablettes des robots ou de
la visio conférences sont également
encouragées le vs cul dans le top 15 des
universités françaises selon un
classement international le classement
turcs eurent ap place l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines à
la 15e position nationale une
progression de quatre places par rapport
au même classement l'an passé eu rapt
tient compte des activités académiques
de l'établissement le nombre de
publications dans le web of science par
exemple au niveau mondial uvs cul et est
classé 336e sur 2500 d'après ce palmarès
on referme cette page dédiée à
l'éducation à trappes mardi des
professeurs du collège le village
manifester ils réclament l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle classe dans
l'établissement où le nombre d'élèves
augmente il dénonce des effectifs
surchargés une moyenne de 24 élèves par
classe beaucoup trop selon eux pour un
collège du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire
écoutez ses propos au micro de manon
varaldo et patrick jacques de dixmude
donc faut savoir qu'au collège on a
parlé salle pour accueillir plus que 24
élèves
on a donc on doit mettre les élèves
contre le tableau sur des tables et les
chaises
vous visez et c'est malheureusement le
niveau qui a le plus souffert en termes
de contenus de cours parce qu'elles ont
été gênés par le trop d'élèves à gérer
en même temps ce qui fait qu'on a eu
beaucoup d'exclusion cette année en
quatrième 45 % de nos exclusion de deux
classes c'est simplement pas le niveau
4e qui était qui s'explique je pense
justement par sa part le par le trop
nombre le long trop élevé d'élèves c'est
l'un des tout premiers en france la
ville de poissy a inauguré mercredi un
puits de carbone système et écologique
il purifie l'air à partir de co2 dégagé
notamment par les voitures
et ce grâce à des micro algues cette
première a également une portée
pédagogique auprès des plus jeunes les
explications de michael et demi d'euros
le quartier de la gare de poissy devrait
à mieux respirer la ville a inauguré ce
mercredi 22 mai un puits de carbone le
premier des yvelines objectif de ce
dispositif lancé après deux ans
d'expérimentation lutter contre la
pollution atmosphérique notamment le co2
dégagées par les voitures
le principe est le principe de la
photosynthèse on prend de l'air vicié
que l'on injecte dans la colonne dans
cette colonne nous avons mis de l'eau et
des microalgues que nous éclairons
continue et le fait de combiner les
clairement plus pollution d'un air vicié
les micro algues vont capter cet air
vicié se reproduire et purifier l'air
ainsi le totem de deux mètres cinquante
a été loué par la ville de poissy
jusqu'à l'année prochaine pour une
période de test coût total de
l'opération à 20000 euros la commune
espère également sensibiliser les
passants sur l'environnement nous
aimerions que les gens se posent la
question parce qu'un aspect pédagogique
qui est très important pour nous qu'il
se dise bah tiens il ya peut-être des
solutions au niveau
du développement durable au niveau de la
défense de l'environnement et qu'ils
prennent conscience de tous ces enjeux
si l'expérience est concluante sur cette
première année le puits de carbone
devrait être renouvelée à part la ville
une idée de sortie originale à présent
pour votre week end jusqu'à samedi le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille l'extraction
challenge une compétition entre pompiers
durant trois jours 19 équipes de toute
la france et même certaines d'autres
pays s'affrontent dans des épreuves
d'extraction d'accidentés de la route
objectif qualification pour les
championnats internationaux en afrique
du sud sur place jeudi matin pour le
début de la compétition marylène yapi
chino
les accidents spectaculaires en plein
centre du vélodrome de montigny le
bretonneux des pompiers de toute la
france se sont donné rendez vous pour
montrer leurs meilleures techniques de
désincarcération et de prise en charge
des accidentés de la route ce matin
l'équipe des alpes-maritimes tenter de
relever le challenge
il avait un cas très difficile avec deux
personnes qui étaient incarcérés dans la
voiture retournée sur le toit
ils se sont bien débrouillés dix neuf
équipes françaises et trois équipes
internationales sont venus participer à
cette troisième édition la compétition
tourne autour de deux épreuves 10
minutes pour extraire une victime
trente minutes quand il y en a deux un
véritable travail d'équipé
orchestré par le capitaine sam vesty le
partage de la connaissance autour du
monde sap accompli la désincarcération
c'est un objectif qui portait depuis
les dizaines une dizaine d'années au
travers le monde la france s'est inscrit
dans cette technique depuis trois ans
pour la première fois cette année le
département d évident à sa propre équipe
les huit pompiers se sont entraînés
depuis le mois de janvier pour ces
épreuves prévues vendredi et samedi
c'est une envie ça fait partie de nos
missions aussi de tous les jours en cas
de sapeurs pompiers ça demande un petit
peu des techniques l'utilisation de
matériel et puis aussi un petit peu de
réflexion au niveau des accidents de la
route par l'événement est ouvert au
public et pour l'occasion un espace
prévention est mise en place à
l'extérieur
deux mille cinq cents collégiens et
lycéens yvelinois sont sensibilisés aux
risques de la route à travers différents
simulateurs
histoire de rappeler qu'avant de
désincarcérer mieux vaut éviter
l'accident
[Musique]
on leur fait prendre conscience de leur
fragilité
un âge où ils se sentent vraiment très
très fort et ou deviennent de plus en
plus c'est pourquoi ils prennent
davantage de risques et c'est pourquoi
malheureusement les jeunes de 15-24 ans
sont deux fois plus sinistrées sur la
route que les autres tranches d'âge
le challenge extraction des sapeurs
pompiers se poursuit jusqu'à samedi le
vainqueur se qualifiera pour le
championnat mondial cette année en
afrique du sud et donc l'extraction
challenge c'est au vélodrome jusqu'à
samedi soir
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv2 60 18 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre
application tv 78 et notre site internet
tv 78 points comme bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]